[Music]
and
in my dreams i've kissed your lips
a thousand times
hang on what is he doing here
i believe it's pronounced thank you for
what
uh for saving your life again and again
and again you
said baby get me michael brice
what no no no no no
i said baby i need help get anywhere
but michael bryce what he
is the most annoying excuse me
i have 20 20 hearing i can hear you the
dead guys
can hear you how many times have you
nearly got me killed
not enough come on baby let's get out of
here before he starts the in-flight
safety demonstration
he has had a tremendous year michael
bryce is the bodyguard of the year
[Laughter]
[Music]
is he a relative of yours god no darius
kincaid's a hitman one for like a
zillion murders around the world
and how often do you have this dream
just once well that's not tonight
right i'm thinking you need to forget
bodyguarding
[Music]
i'm officially on sabbatical and to be
honest i don't know why i didn't do this
sooner
[Music]
this is the world's been waiting for me
to make this change
for the first time i'm starting to
imagine a life without
psychological orders
i promised my therapist no bodyguard
that means no guns no killing and no
blood
what is he doing here ah
are you using pepper spray i'm on
sabbatical
how many times you nearly got me killed
not enough
i would make a great mother don't you
think oh my god a child would be so
lucky to have you as its host
i on the other hand will tell you
everything
[Music]
you